You came back for more, that's awesome.
So let's talk about what products can do for us.
How they give us value that we're willing to pay for.
Products can do one or a combination of three things.
They can do things cheaper than competitors.
They can outperform competitors or they can make you
feel differently and perhaps better than competitors.
So a car can give us value because it's cheaper than a competitor or it can be more fuel
efficient or maybe it's just got
a cool logo that makes us feel proud to drive it, or all three.
Branding, which is a set of associations that a consumer
has about a product is an example of psychological value.
A brand is meant to make a consumer feel a certain way.
It doesn't change how fast the car drives,
it changes how exciting that ride feels.
People are willing to pay for products that are branded because
they value the feelings of the specific brand gives them.
Some people feel that brands and branding are wrong.
There was even a book called,
"No Logo," that criticized the ultra branded world in which we live.
But if brands are wrong,
then feelings are wrong,
and I don't think that anyone would argue
that there's something bad about having feelings,
even about things we consume.
Let's talk about an example of an unconventional brand.
You might not have heard the name Calvin Cordozar Broadus Jr.,
but you probably are familiar with Snoop Doggy Dogg.
Snoop created his brand by
capitalizing on the fact that people were interested in his music,
but he didn't limit himself to music.
He use his music as a platform to entice listeners to find out more about himself.
Snoop Dogg made elements of himself,
elements that have nothing to do with music,
available for the public to see.
So he created a TV game show.
He appeared to football games.
He did a cooking special with Martha Stewart.
He even created a nature show called Plizzanet Earth.
Essentially, he helped fans generate associations and feelings about him,
and not simply his rap and its lyrics.
Through marketing, Snoop was able to move from being
just a voice in people's minds to a personality that they care to discover.
He licensed his likeness and use PR to generate press and TV appearances.
In addition, his ubiquity included participation in other musicians' work.
Even more mainstream pop like Katy Perry and Miley Cyrus,
the Pussy Cat Dolls,
Mariah Carey, and some hip hop like Matoma.
Here's the thing about psychological value that's so important.
Psychological value provides a form of differentiation that consumers care
about and create reasons to buy
something when a product is otherwise the same functionally.
Think of a car. All cars have engines,
many of the same size and power,
and many features are exactly the same.
So what makes you buy a BMW over an Audi or
Mercedes when their performance and price are very similar.
The big differences are in the associations we have with each brand.
Those associations are pure psychological value.
When BMW calls itself the Ultimate Driving Machine,
it's appealing to one element in our psychology that is different from Audis,
which says, "never blend in,"
kind of like Snoop Dogg.